NARRATOR: University
at Irvine, April 2017.
Aerospace Engineer Travis
Taylor has obtained a model
of an aircraft whose design
specifications are based solely
on information gleaned
from ancient Indian text
that are believed to
have been formally
set to writing in 500 BC.
He is going to
subjected to wind tunnel
analysis to determine if it
is a viable flying machine.
So explain to
me what we've set
up here with that wind tunnel.
OK, so this is our
air space vehicle model.
It's connected to this boom.
The armature has a
force gauge on it.
But we're going to have
airflow go past it at about
50 miles per hour or so.
And then we're going to
measure forces against it
to determine if it's
going to fly or not.
And so what are the signs
that you're looking for in order
to determine whether this is,
in fact, aerodynamically sound?
Right, so we're going to
measure the normal force.
And the normal
force is up or down.
If it starts to
move up, then that
will be exciting, because it's
actually going to be rising.
And that's how you get flight.
You know, when an airplane
turns up and starts to move,
it's because it's getting lift.
The other thing is I don't want
to see it going real bad, side
to side or real bad,
chatter up and down,
because that would
mean it's unstable.
All right, well, let's do it.
Let's fire her up
and see what happens.
Yeah, let's do it.
[suspense music]
The flow is
coming up in speed.
Yep.
NARRATOR: While being subjected
to 50-mile-an-hour winds,
the craft exhibits a
slight lift upwards,
yet remains relatively steady.
TRAVIS TAYLOR: No
side-to-side wobble.
OK.
NARRATOR: Sensors record the
measurements of various forces,
as well as torque and
pitch to determine just
how aerodynamic the body is.
It looks very stable.
[suspense music]
[craft noise]
All right, so let's
look at the results.
So what happened
during the test
was the normal force, which
is where we measure the lift,
it was positive between 0.03
and 0.06 pounds of force.
That means we were
measuring lift.
So our vehicle in the
wind tunnel experiment
was showing positive lift
like an aircraft would.
Did you expect these results
from a shape that's like that?
Well, the shape looks
like a lifting body to me.
But you never know until you
actually do the experiment.
And we have experimental
results now that says it is.
So that's the exciting part.
And what do you say to
anyone who questions the idea
that this information has
been taken from a text that's
at least 1,800 years old?
The only thing you
can say is we performed
a good scientific experiment.
And the results were that the
shape made from those tags
is a viable
aerodynamic structure.
[suspense music]
NARRATOR: The aircraft
model created,
using details garnered from
the ancient Indian texts
has proven to be flight worthy.
Is it possible that by studying
the ancient Indian texts,
we may be able to recreate
advanced technology that
existed thousands of
years ago in India?
Ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
that the texts may
also contain details
for advanced spacecraft.
[suspense music]